[Music]
we talk about surgical robots is also a
talk about surgery and while I've tried
to make my images not too graphic keep
in mind that surgeons have a different
relationship with blood than normal
people do because after all what a
surgeon does to a patient if it were
done without consent would be a felony
surgeons are the tailors the plumbers
the carpenters some would say the
butchers of the medical world cutting
reshaping reforming bypassing fixing but
you need to talk about surgical
instruments and the evolution of
surgical technology together so in order
to give you some kind of a perspective
of where we are right now with surgical
robots and where we're going to be going
in the future I want to give you a
little bit of perspective of how we've
got to this point
I mean how we even came to believe that
surgery was okay that this was something
that was possible to do that this kind
of cutting and reforming was okay so a
little bit of perspective about 10,000
years of perspective so this is a
trephination skull and trephination is
simply just cutting a hole in the skull
and many many hundreds of skulls like
this have been found in archaeological
sites all over the world dating back
five to ten thousand years five to ten
thousand years now imagine this you are
a healer in a Stone Age village and you
have some guy that you're not quite sure
what's wrong with him Oliver Sacks is
going to be born way in the future he's
got some seizure disorder and you don't
understand this but you think to
yourself not quite sure what's wrong
with this guy but maybe like cut a hole
in his head I can fix it
now that surgical thinking you know
we've got the dawn of interventional
surgery here
what is astonishing about this is even
though we don't know really how much of
this was intended to be religious or how
much of it was intended to be
therapeutic what we can tell is that
these patients lived judging by the
healing on the borders of these holes
they live days months years following
Trece nation and so what we're seeing is
evidence of a refined technique that was
being handed down over thousands and
thousands of years all over the world
this arose independently at sites
everywhere that had no communication to
one another we really are seeing the
dawn of interventional surgery now we
can fast forward many thousands of years
into the Bronze Age and beyond and we
see new refined tools coming out but
surgeons in these eras are a little bit
more conservative than their bold
treffen ating ancestors these guys
confined their surgery to fairly
superficial injuries and surgeons were
tradesmen rather than physicians this
persisted all the way into and through
the Renaissance that may have saved the
writers but it didn't really save the
surgeons terribly much they were still a
mistrusted lot surgeons still had a bit
of a PR problem because the landscape
was dominated by the itinerant barber
surgeon these were folks that traveled
from village to village town to town
doing surgery sort of as a form of
performance art because we're in the age
before anesthesia and the agony of the
patient is really as much of the public
spectacle as the surgery itself one of
the most famous of these guys
Frere Jacques shown here doing a
lithotomy the removal of the bladder
stone one of the most invasive surgeries
they did at the time had to take less
than two minutes you had to have quite a
flair for the dramatic and really really
quick and so here you see him doing the
lithotomy and he's credited with doing
over 4,000 of these public surgeries
wandering around in Europe which is an
astonishing number when you think that
surgery must have been
last resort I mean who would put
themselves through that until anesthesia
the absence of sensation with the
demonstration of the Morton ether
inhaler at the Mass General in 1847 a
whole new era of surgery was ushered in
anesthesia gave surgeons the freedom to
operate anesthesia gave them the freedom
to experiment to start to delve deeper
into the body but this was truly a
revolution in surgery
but there was a pretty big problem with
this after these very long painstaking
operations attempting to cure things
they've never been able to touch before
the patients died they died of massive
infection surgery didn't hurt anymore
but it killed you pretty quickly and
infection would continue to claim a
majority of surgical patients until the
next big revolution in surgery which was
aseptic technique now Joseph Lister was
a sepsis Azur sterility 'he's biggest
advocate to a very very skeptical bunch
of surgeons but eventually they did come
around the Mayo brothers came out to
visit Lister in Europe and I came back
to their American clinic and they said
they had learned it was as important to
wash your hands before doing surgery as
it was to wash up afterwards something's
so simple and yet operative mortality
dropped profoundly these surgeries were
actually now being effective with the
patient insensitive to pain and a
sterile operating field all bets were
off the sky was the limit you could now
start doing surgery everywhere on the
gut on the liver on the heart on the
brain transplantation you could take an
organ out of one person you could put it
in another person and it would work
surgeons didn't have a problem with
respectability more they had become gods
the era of the big surgeon big
had arrived but at quite a cost because
they're saving lives but not necessarily
quality of life because healthy people
don't usually need surgery and unhealthy
people have a very hard time recovering
from a cut like that and the question
had to be asked well can we do these
same surgeries but through little
incisions laparoscopy is doing this kind
of surgery surgery with long instruments
through small incisions and it really
changed the landscape of surgery some of
the tools for this had been around for a
hundred years but it had only been used
as a diagnostic technique until the
1980s when there was changes in camera
technologies and things like that that
allowed this to be done for real
operations so what you see this is now
the first surgical image as we're coming
down the tube this is a new entry into
the body it looks very different from
what you're expecting surgery to look
like we bring instruments in from two
separate cuts in the side and then you
can start manipulating tissue within ten
years of the first gallbladder surgeries
being done laparoscopically a majority
of gallbladder surgeries were being done
laparoscopically truly a pretty big
revolution but there were casualties to
this revolution these techniques were a
lot harder to learn than people had
anticipated the learning curve was very
long and during that learning curve the
complications went quite a bit higher
surgeons had to give up their 3d vision
they had to give up their wrists they
had to give up intuitive motion of the
instruments this surgeon has over 3,000
hours of laparoscopic experience now
this is a particularly frustrating
placement of the needle but this is hard
and one of the reasons why it is so hard
is because the external organ Onex are
terrible you've got these long
instruments and you're working off your
son
line and the instruments are essentially
working backwards and so what you need
to do to take the capability of your
hand and put it on the other side of
that small incision is you need to put a
wrist on that instrument and so I get to
talk about robots The DaVinci robot put
just that wrist on the other side of
that incision and so here you're seeing
the operation of this wrist and now in
contrast to the laparoscopy you can
precisely place the needle in your
instruments and you can pass it all the
way through and follow it in a
trajectory and the reason why this
becomes so much easier as you can see on
the bottom the hands are making the
motions and the instruments are
following those motions exactly now what
you put between those instruments and
those hands is a large fairly
complicated robot a surgeon's sitting at
a console and controlling the robot with
these controllers and the robot is
moving the instruments around and
powering them down inside the body you
have a 3d camera so you get a 3d view
and since this was introduced in 1999 a
lot of these robots have been out and
being used for surgical procedures like
a prostatectomy which is a prostate deep
in the pelvis and it requires fine
dissection and delicate manipulation to
be able to get a good surgical outcome
you can also so bypass vessels directly
on to a beating heart without cracking
the chest this is all done in between
the ribs and you can go inside the heart
itself and repair the valves from the
inside you've got these technologies
thank you
and so you might say wow this is really
cool so smartypants why isn't old
surgery being done this way and there
are some reasons there's some good
reasons and cost is one of them I talked
about the large complicated robot with
all its bells and whistles one of those
robots will cost you about as much as a
solid-gold surgeon more useful than a
solid-gold surgeon but still it's a
fairly big capital investment but once
you've got it you your procedure costs
do come down but there are other
barriers so something like a
prostatectomy the prostate is small and
it's in one spot and you can set your
robot up very precisely to work in that
one spot and so it's perfect
for something like that and in fact if
you or anyone you know had their
prostate taken out in the last couple of
years chances are it was done with one
of these systems but if you need to
reach more places than just one you need
to move the robot and you need to put
some new incisions in there and you need
to reset it up and then you need to add
some more ports and more and the problem
is it gets time-consuming and cumbersome
and for that reason there are many
surgeries that just aren't being done
with the DaVinci so we had to ask the
question well how do we fix that what if
we could change it so that we didn't
have to reset up each time we wanted to
move somewhere different what if we
could bring all of the instruments in
together in one place how would that
change the capabilities of the surgeon
and how that changed the experience for
the patient now to do that we need to be
able to bring a camera and instruments
in together through one small tube like
that tube you saw in the laparoscopy
video or not so coincidentally like a
tube like this so what's going to come
out of that tube is they debuted this
new technology this new robot that is
going to be able to reach anywhere ready
so here it comes this is the camera in
three instruments and as you see it come
out in order to actually be able to do
anything useful it can't all stay
clustered up like this it has to be able
to come off of the center line and then
be able to work back towards that center
line and he's a cheeky little devil but
what this lets you do is gives you that
all-important traction and counter
traction so that you can dissect so that
you can so so they can do all the things
that you need to do all the surgical
tasks but it's all coming in through one
incision it's not so simple but it's
worth it for the freedom that this gives
us as we're going around for the patient
however it's transparent this is all
they're going to see it's very exciting
to think where we get to go with this we
get to write the script of the next
revolution in surgery as we take these
capabilities and we get to go to the
next places we get to decide what our
new surgeries are going to be and I
think to really get the rest of the way
in that revolution we need to not just
take our hands in in new ways but we
also need to take our eyes in in new
ways we need to see beyond the surface
we need to be able to guide what we're
cutting in a much better way this is a
cancer surgery one of the problems with
this even for surgeons who've been
looking at this a lot is you can't see
the cancer especially when it's hidden
below the surface and so what we're
starting to do is we're starting to
inject specially-designed markers into
the bloodstream that will target the
cancer and they'll go bind to the cancer
and we can make those markers glow and
we can take special cameras and we can
look at it and now we know where we need
to cut even when it's below the surface
we can take these markers and
can inject them in a tumor site and we
can follow where they flow out from that
tumor site so that we can see the first
places where that cancer might travel we
can inject these dyes into the
bloodstream so that when we do a new
vessel and we bypass a blockage on the
heart we can see if we actually made the
connection before we close that patient
back up again something that we haven't
been able to do without radiation before
we can light up tumors like this kidney
tumor so that you can exactly see where
the boundary is between the kidney tumor
and the kidney you want to leave behind
or the liver tumor and the liver you
want to leave behind and we don't even
need to confine ourselves to this macro
vision we have flexible microscopic
probes that we can bring down into the
body and we can look at cells directly
I'm looking at nerves here so these are
nerves you see down on the bottom and
the microscope probe that's being held
by the robotic hand up at the top so
this is all very prototype II at this
point but you care about nerves if you
are a surgical patient because they let
you keep continents bladder control and
sexual function after surgery all of
which is generally fairly important to
the patient so with the combination of
these technologies we can reach it all
and we can see it all we can heal the
disease and we can leave the patient
whole and intact and functional
afterwards now I've talked about the
patient as if the patient is somehow
someone abstract outside this room and
that is not the case many of you all of
you maybe will at some point or have
already faced a diagnosis of cancer or
heart disease or some organ dysfunction
that's going to buy you a date with a
surgeon and when you get to that point I
mean
these maladies don't care how many books
you've written how many companies you've
started that Nobel Prize you have yet to
win how much time you planned to spend
with your children these maladies come
for us all and the prospect I'm offering
you of an easier surgery is that gonna
make that diagnosis any less terrifying
I'm not sure I really even want it to
because facing your own mortality causes
a revaluation of priorities and a
realignment of what your goals are in
life unlike anything else and I would
never want to deprive you of that
epiphany what I want instead is for you
to be whole intact and functional enough
to go out and save the world after
you've decided you need to do it and
that is my vision for your future thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
35 the most times an athlete has broken
the pole-vault world record 80 the
lengthen minutes of the longest standing
ovation 18 the highest number of
Michelin stars a chef has ever been
awarded
there is always something to challenge
[Music]
my name is Kevin Rivera I work for BMW
North America I am the field marketing
operations manager in the western region
we are very glad to have members of the
Ted organization with us here today it's
a very exciting to share this
partnership with BMW North America and
the TED conference we are very excited
about sharing out some of our ideas that
come from our designers our teams our
members to create something from an idea
into an actual product to the consumer
today we've got a special treat for you
guys here our newest product seven years
in the making they're incredibly fast
yet efficient technologically advanced
and completely redesigned the all-new
2009 BMW 7 Series now let's talk a
little bit about the technology that's
in the car the lane departure and lane
change warning systems so the radars in
the rear of the car will actually look
to the side so if you're going to change
lanes and you put on your blinker
there's a light in each of the mirrors
that will either glow red if there's a
car there or not glow at all so you
don't have to worry about your blind
spots as much what I love about the new
7 is that I think it really has taken
the best design elements of the current
series and the prior series
it feels lower sleeker more muscular
really liked the changes and inside I
really like the instrument panel and how
things were laid out some very nice
changes to it I'm in the design field
and it just feels like somebody really
thought through the process of design
and it it has a real personality and
emotion to it which i think is lacking
in so many cars
it was extremely informative from the
president to the designers to LA and the
kids work on things it couldn't have
been better it was superb